أنت بالطبع أعارض تمامًا
فكرة زواج الفتيات نوعًا ما
دون السن القانونية وأيضًا عدم وجود
سن قانوني للزواج في اليمن ، لم
يكن هناك حقًا فكرة أنني كنت أحاول
الوصول إليها على الرغم من ذلك في المشهد في
الفيلم  حيث أواجه والدي
بشأن اقتراح زواج محتمل
أنه تعلم أنه اتصل
بي عندما كان عمري 15 عامًا ،
كان الأمر أكثر من تسليط الضوء على نوع
النزاعات الاجتماعية التي
تحدث في  الأسرة على أساس يومي في
اليمن لا ، لذلك أردت أن تعرف
نوعًا ما من إلقاء الضوء على بعض
الجوانب الإيجابية لليمن
والشعب والثقافة والمجتمع ،
وبدلاً من أن تعرف مرة أخرى فقط
لتجربة شيء سلبي
و  عندما كان عمري 17 عامًا ، قررت أخيرًا
الانتقال إلى اسكتلندا حيث تعيش والدتي
بالطبع أنت تعلم أن هذه
المحادثة يجب أن تبدأ في مكان ما
ويجب أن يحدث هذا النقاش في
مكان ما ويجب على شخص تعرفه أن
يكون شجاعًا بما فيه الكفاية  س فقط ضعوا
أنفسهم هناك بدلاً من
التعبير حتى تعرف أن عائلتي كانت
مفيدة وداعمة بشكل لا يصدق
في المكسرات ، فأنت تعلم أين
وضعوا أنفسهم أمام
الكاميرا وكشفت أنك تعرف بعض
القضايا الرئيسية حقًا في اليمن ، لديك أي
مجتمع وأنا  لا أعتقد أنه
غير ذي صلة باليمنيين ، كل شيء ، لذا فهو
شيء يمكن أن يرتبط به اليمنيون ،
لكنني أردت أيضًا أن أفعل ذلك بطريقة تجعلهم
يحققون تحولًا عالميًا حقًا.